Carmel Martin I'm the executive vice
president for policy here at the Center
for American Progress thank you for
joining us today for this important
discussion of the threats to our
democracy arising from president Trump's
many conflicts of interest and seeming
disregard for core democratic norms
we're lucky to have a terrific panel
with us today and a leading voice on
democracy issues congressman sarbanes
Trump's refusal to divest himself of
ownership over his sprawling businesses
means he has assumed power with the
gravest set of conflicts ever facing an
American president what's worse is that
we don't know the extent of his
financial conflicts including
significant debt held by foreign banks
because he continues to hide his tax
returns this is especially concerning in
terms of the continuing revelations of
his ties to Russia there is every reason
to worry that foreign businesses and
governments will have too much influence
over Trump's decisions and that Trump
will provide special favors and
treatment to his business partners
already a month into his presidency the
Trump's continue to promote the private
business interest going so far as to
have their products hocked from the
White House briefing room we are honored
to have congressman sarbanes join us at
cap today because he has distinguished
himself as a leader in Capitol Hill in
fighting for political reform and
against big money in politics in light
of his leadership the congressman was
appointed to lead the house democracy
reform task force and leader Pelosi
called congressman sarbanes a relentless
champion fighting for the integrity and
transparency that hard-working American
families expect from our elected
officials already the task force has
taken bold steps to advance the
government by the people act a
comprehensive plan spearheaded by the
congressman to strengthen our democracy
the task force has also been working to
confront the Trump administration's
conflicts and expose the special
interest driving much of the current
agenda on Capitol Hill congressman
sarbanes has represented Maryland's
third District in the US House of
Representatives for the past decade
we're proud to have congressman sarbanes
working with us here today to bring
light to the threats to democratic norms
and to discuss how we can fight back
please join me in welcoming the
congressman good afternoon everybody it
is it's great to be here I want to thank
you Carmel for your introduction I want
to thank cap the Center for American
Progress for inviting me here today and
hosting this very very important
discussion I'm not sure there's a more
important discussion that we could be
having at this particular time I want to
thank you Carmel for joining us recently
at the democracy reform taskforce to
present some of the work that caps been
doing in a course today is another
occasion to release some important
information that's relevant to this
topic of conflicts of interest I also
want to thank Liz Kennedy for her great
work and her continued support I'm
looking forward to the discussion today
from ambassador Eisen and Robert Wiseman
and Vikram Singh we got a terrific panel
that we're looking forward to so here's
why I'm gonna start this this discussion
Donald Trump told us told us told the
American people that he was gonna look
out for us that he was gonna fight for
us that's what he said little over four
weeks ago it seems like it seems like
eons ago but four weeks ago I sat there
on the west front of the Capitol and I
heard the president make a very
important and central promise to the
American people here's what he said for
too long
a small group in our nation's capitol
has reaped the rewards of government
while the people have borne the cost
Washington flourished but the people did
not share in its wealth politicians
prospered but the jobs left and the
factories closed the establishment
protected itself but not the citizens of
our country that all changes he said
starting right here and right now
because today we are not merely
transferring power from one
administration to another or from one
party to another we are transferring
power from Washington DC and back to you
the people that's what he said at his
inauguration now I trust that most of
you in this room when you heard that
promise and I think many Americans when
you heard it it rang hollow you saw it
for what it was rhetoric that was
designed to distract from what we now
see are the president's real motives you
were right to be wary of that promise
president and Trump does not appear to
be transferring power to the people what
he seems to be doing is pulling the
power closer to himself to his family to
his brand to his business and to his
buddies he's broken from all precedent
as Carmel alluded to a moment ago by
entering office with a sprawling web of
business assets and conflicts of
interests all too eager it seems to
subordinate the office of the presidency
to the interests of the Trump
Organization he has floated the
Constitution by receiving numerous
emoluments both foreign and domestic and
will continue to do so should he not
take meaningful steps to relinquish
ownership of his many business assets
and he's shown no inclination to do that
and he has been unrepentant in
repeatedly refusing to adhere to the
basic norms of integrity that have
always governed our nation's highest
office even rebuffing the chorus of
Americans of all political stripes who
are asking that he release his tax
returns a minimal expression
of acknowledgment and appreciation of
these basic standards to make matters
worse the president has surrounded
himself we're pretty much through the
cabinet appointment process at this time
with a cabinet full of senior officials
who themselves appear to be rife with
similar conflicts of interest taking a
cue from the top and they're primed to
capitalize on their newfound positions
of power these are not the actions of a
man committed to giving power back to
the people or to lifting up the voice of
the voiceless who feel left behind by a
broken system in Washington but the
reason I read the president's words at
the outset from his inauguration is I
wanted to ground the discussion here
today to remind each of us the assembled
experts the press concerned citizens
that out in the country his promise to
give power back to the powerless and the
disrespected to give a voice to the
voiceless still has great resonance and
appeal and the truth is that if people
believe he's making good on that promise
then his ethical lapses and his
conflicts of interest will be viewed as
tolerable for those who seek to preserve
our democracy and the ethical norms and
laws which undergird it this is our
challenge forging and understanding in
the public that president Trump's
contempt for basic standards of trust
and integrity is not trivial it is not a
harmless sideshow rather it strikes at
the core of his ability to serve the
people
it harms their interest the public
interests now lot of ink has been
spilled and will probably continue to be
spilled chronicling the president's
breathtaking number of conflicts let me
just cite a few for the record his 940
million dollar loan from the Bank of
China his unknown level of foreign
investment from Russian oligarchs is
pending trademark litigation
in China his business partnership with
the newly named special envoy from the
Philippines appointed by the brutal
president Rodrigo Duterte
his sons both sons continued pursuit of
business deals every day it seems as
another one around the globe with the
imprimatur now the United States
government being placed on those
ventures his many business assets in
Turkey the United Arab Emirates Saudi
Arabia and elsewhere all of which have
the potential to distort the president's
official actions the list goes on some
Americans including my own constituents
for sure are very closely tracking this
I mean every news story that comes out
that sheds light on the president's
conflicts of interest they're watching
this they're deeply concerned about his
cabinet officials and the policy that he
might pursue but many and certainly it
seems the vast majority of Republican
voters are not yet concerned by these
conflicts he may be a scoundrel some
people might say but he's our scoundrel
no surprise then that my colleagues in
Congress when the other side of the
aisle have been unwilling to engage in
meaningful oversight of the new
administration but here's the point we
need to make and I really want to
emphasize this president Trump is not
just suffering from petty lapses that
will somehow somehow come out in the
wash over time instead his complete
disregard for ethical norms and the
constitutional protections against
corruption if unchecked will cause grave
harm to our nation as a whole
and to the situation of everyday
Americans his conduct threatens to
weaken our national security to corrode
people's faith in our institutions of
democracy and to advance special
interests at the expense of the public
interests
put bluntly the president is breaking
his promise he is aggrandize empower to
himself not transferring it back to the
American people
that is why discussions like the one
being held today are so important we
must begin to bring clarity to how
president Trump's corruption affects how
it harms the interests of regular
Americans otherwise they'll give him a
pass and our call to arms will be just
an academic exercise
the white paper being released today by
the Center for American Progress written
by Liz Kennedy and Danielle root lays
bare the risk posed by Trump's many
conflicts of interests and those of his
cabinet it details how those conflicts
of interests are risk to national
security to u.s. foreign policy to the
integrity of US elections to the free
and fair operation of US economic
markets and to the dedication to the
public interest and the rule of law to
reiterate we must embrace an analysis of
the president's conduct that makes clear
that his conflicts and those of his
cabinet do in fact harm the public
interest this paper and I hope the
discussion that follows today will help
make the turn in the public debate from
an ever-expanding laundry list of
jarring conflicts to a more sober
analysis of how those conflicts imperil
the interests of American households and
the broader public interests this is
critical and I applaud the Center for
American Progress where it's work I want
to offer a sober reminder about the role
of congressional oversight picking up on
my earlier comments President Trump has
been present for a little over a month
and it's important to remember there are
47 months to go so pace yourselves
while Republican leadership has been
reluctant to engage in any meaningful
oversight of the conflicts that I've
discussed and will hear more about today
the politics of the moment are not
static
just this week Americans across the
country as you know have been flooding
town halls urging their representatives
to take oversight of the administration
seriously members of Congress who
ignored those calls do so at their own
peril and again I firmly believe the
more the public focuses on the specific
harm of Trump's conflicts the more that
pressure will build as the current chair
of the house democracy reform task force
I can assure you House Democrats will be
at the forefront in exposing the risks
the president Trump's conflicts present
we are already pursuing remedies that
can bring about the oversight that is
demanded Democrats this week in the
House Judiciary Committee will vote on a
resolution of inquiry from my colleague
Jerry Nadler that would begin
investigations into the Trump
administration's conflicts of interests
and potential improper ties to Russia
Republicans are likely to block this
effort but they'll have to explain if
they do in the same vein many of my
colleagues have authored legislation
that would require President Trump to
release his taxes thereby offering a
full picture of his finances and sources
of conflicts the task force is also
making plans to go outside the Beltway
holding field hearings across the
country on these issues and allowing
Americans of all political stripes to
learn more about the risks that we face
the paper that you've released today
will be very important to that effort
and finally we're working daily with our
standing committees in the house and our
partners in the Senate to monitor
emerging risks and to seek answers from
the administration when appropriate
President Trump promised at his
inauguration to give power back to the
powerless and to give a voice to the
voiceless Americans must insist that he
follow through on that promise and if he
doesn't follow through they have to hold
him accountable with reports like the
one being released today we can empower
Americans to judge for themselves in
other words let's give people the
information let them draw the conclusion
about whether the president is operating
with divided loyalties
whether he's looking out for the people
or he's looking out for himself I want
to finish today by reading an excerpt
from a book called Lincoln on leadership
by Donald Phillips a couple paragraphs
which I think can kind of drive home
point of this integrity so I'm going to
put my glasses on for this part the
moniker Honest Abe was resurrected for
the presidential campaign in 1860 a
major component of the Republican
campaign hype it was plastered on
campaign posters and appeared in
cartoons and newspapers across the
country it was all part of a national
crusade the pain at Lincoln is one of
the common people a rail splitter from
Illinois who was honest beyond question
it has remained in the American stream
of consciousness to this day as perhaps
the most glorified part of the Lincoln
myth but as American philosopher William
Ernest Hawking noted there are myths
which displace truth and their myths
which give wings to truth in this case
Abraham Lincoln's reputation for honesty
and integrity even though challenged
over the years has remained unblemished
in fact as knowledge is gained about the
real man it is largely enhanced myth in
this case has become reality
Lincoln was just as honest as he has
been purported to be if not more so
without question
honesty is one of the major qualities
that made him a great leader the
architecture of leadership all the
theories and guidelines falls apart
without
honesty and integrity it's the Keystone
that holds an organization together Tom
Peters reported in his research that the
best most aggressive and successful
organizations were the ones that
stressed integrity and Trust without
doubt he stated honesty has always been
the best policy managers do things right
leaders do the right thing and John
James McGregor burns warned divorced
from ethics leadership is reduced to
management and politics to mere
technique that's good stuff
reading that looking at our history I'm
convinced that there resides deep in the
psyche of the American people and
abiding appreciation of integrity and
honesty in their leaders depart from
that on occasion and the people can
forgive make it your operating procedure
to dissemble and deceive and the
consequence can and should be severe
Americans need to ask very simply whose
side is the President on and can we
trust him their answer to that question
will decide his political fate thank you
all very much
[Applause]
thank you so much to representative
sarbanes for those really terrific
remarks I think beautifully explaining
the extent of the situation we're
currently facing and we'll be focusing
on the real consequences here today with
this distinguished panel all of whom are
now here but I think I really appreciate
that grounding us in the real strength
of America's democracy through the years
is really a question of integrity so I'm
joined today I'm Liz Kennedy the
director of democracy and government
reform here at the Center for American
Progress thank you so much all for
joining us and I'm joined by rob
Weissman Robert Wiseman the president of
public citizens since 2009 Public
Citizen prides itself on being a
countervailing force to corporate power
their work in championing citizens
interests before Congress the executive
branch agencies and the courts is all to
ensure that all citizens are represented
in the halls of power before working at
Public Citizen Wiseman was the director
of corporate accountability at essential
action so thank you for joining us here
today norm iseman founder and back as
chair of the Citizens for responsibility
and ethics in Washington crew crew works
to reduce the influence of money in
politics and help foster a government
that is ethical and accountable he is a
fellow with the governance studies at
Brookings and before that he served as
the US ambassador to the Czech Republic
under Obama under the Obama
administration and President Obama's
ethics are where he helped to you know
establish the ethical practices of that
administration so lots to share from
norm and then really thrilled to be
joined by my colleague and I think an
important voice in these in this
question of the dangerous impacts of
trumps conflicts Vikram Singh is a vice
president for national security and
international policy at cap previously
he served as the deputy assistant
secretary of defense for South and
Southeast Asia at the Pentagon
until November 2011 Singh was the deputy
Special Representative for Afghanistan
and Pakistan at the u.s. Department of
State he's also served in the US
Department of Defense as a senior
advisor on Afghanistan and Pakistan and
held a number of roles in the Department
of Defense over these many years so
thank you all so much for joining us
let's just start by asking so Rob after
Kellyanne Conway had stood in the White
House briefing room telling Fox viewers
to go by Ivanka's merchandise you said
anyone harboring illusions that there
were some separation between the Trump
administration and the Trump family
business has had their fantasies
shattered president Trump and the Trump
administration will use the government
apparatus to advance the interests of
the family business 81% of Americans we
know worry that Trump will allow his
business interests to influence his
decision-making while in office when
Trump prioritizes his own bottom line or
privileges the interests of his business
partners what does that mean for
Americans
how does profiting off the presidency
hurt American families thanks Liz and
thanks for having me here you know I
think that's that's the right question
it's not just for what the rules are in
the sense of what the ethical standards
are and even just sort of what common
sense tells us should be done all of
which the president is routinely
transgressing it's the most important
thing is why does it matter and I think
you know norm has been in the job but I
think the the reason the ethical rules
matter so much is there really
anti-corruption measures and their
design prophylactically to prevent the
corruption of policymaking now we've
never had a president anything like
Donald Trump in many regards but
including as regards his global business
empire it would be one and huge problem
if he was constrained to sort of one
small family business or something but
this is nothing like this and as a
result and because he's refused to
divest his holdings his personal
business interest affects a vast swath
of policy making
the environmental permits likely that
through the EPA or through an executive
order we're going to see that mechanism
soon there's gonna be an effort to roll
back one of the more substantial
environmental rules of the Obama
administration the clean water rule
known as Lotus well one of the main
opponents of the the wotus rules is the
golf course industry ok that's Donald
Trump's industry the overtime rules are
kind of are going to become a source of
contention well one of the main
opponents of that is the hotel industry
we're gonna have a huge fight over
corporate tax reform well we we don't
actually know what President Trump owns
but we know that he's made creative use
of the tax laws and he's bragged about
it so there's no way to have a tax
policy debate that's divorced from his
own personal interest and you go on and
on and on without even getting to the
foreign policy questions and his refusal
to divest is going to have a massive
impact on policymaking affecting
Americans in ways that I think will be
very detrimental as we see unfold over
the next four years or as long as he's
in office
so bring Thank You Rob and I think three
quarters we know three quarters of
Americans at the least but think Trump
should release his tax returns as has
been as noted the practice of every
candidate and president in the modern
era but he continues to Stonewall and
hide them norm what does it mean for
basic democratic norms of public
transparency and accountability that the
president is so cavalierly refusing to
tell Americans what he owes who by
releasing his tax returns Liz thanks for
having me Vikram Rob congressman Carmel
it's a pleasure to be here with all of
you and when I'm on panels with Norm
Ornstein and we get asked about basic
democratic norms we like to joke that
the norms have been violated by this
administration's conduct the I think
that it is a crisis not just of
corruption and not just of Donald Trump
enriching himself and his family and his
associates as Vikram and I will talk
about a little bit the harm to American
foreign policy the risk of war that
comes from this situation but it's also
a crisis of the rule of law and that is
and that is true in the big things how
shocking for our constitutional norms
that we have a president who on the
first day the first hour the minute that
he lifted his hand off of the Bible he
was in violation of the Express and
unambiguous constitutional prohibition
on accepting gifts presents cash or
benefits and this is a quote of any kind
whatever that's what the framers put in
the Constitution in the emoluments cause
because they were so worried about swag
any kind of swag coming to an American
president just for the reasons that Rob
articulates in the foreign policy
context however that it would distort
presidential decision-making to benefit
himself congressman was very eloquent in
talking about the complexities with
China which we now we know has a large
bank loan that he's involved with of
almost a billion dollars we have this
peculiar about-face years of the Chinese
I've been talking about this a lot and a
bipartisan way my bushier a counterpart
professor painter is equally exercised
about it
for years the Chinese denied Donald
Trump a valuable use of the Trump name
the Trump trademark in China suddenly as
he's approaching the threshold of 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue
we're gonna change and they just
registered the first of the changes is
it a coincidence that he also started
out saber rattling on Taiwan and has now
flipped to the jury
one China policy so these constitutional
transgressions are enormous ly
consequential they have a real impact
because when you're talking about China
the unknown Trump financial connections
to Russia with Russian interference in
our democracy peculiar Trump says I do
no business there but his son has said
before he ran for office that Russian
money pervert is a very important cross
section of our assets and that we see a
lot of Russian cash coming in I'm
paraphrasing so which is it we have the
Russia questions then you have all over
the world you have this dictator he's a
killer in the Philippines he admits it
and he said his friend and Trump's
friend and Trump's business partner here
and by the way China and the Philippines
Trump says he's going to defend American
jobs but China and the Philippines are
two places where American jobs have fled
so can we trust him to do that so I
think it's a profound problem and the
small violations Rob and I were very
active on Kellyanne Conway's violation I
was just on CNN this morning talking
about another norm that was violated the
White House chief of staff is not
allowed to talk to the FBI about pending
investigations and we now know that
happened and Donald Trump instead of
saying Oakland Obama he would have been
sent home the chief of staff would have
been sent home while the president and
the senior staff decided if he still had
a job here Donald Trump tweets we we
must crack down on the leakers and
that's what he did with Kellyanne - so
the norms are being violated indeed I
think before we go to the kind of
international consequences as well
staying with thinking about the domestic
sphere and really how all of these in
business relationships impact the
integrity of our economy has also
something I really want to talk about in
terms of the growth of this kind of what
the right is called crony capitalism
which is in fact so Trump is famous
targeted specific American companies for
praise or harangues personally gotten
involved with specific corporate
decisions if Trump is doing his own
business partners and friends favors how
does that impact the integrity of the
economy versus kind of an you know in in
increasing corporate rent-seeking and
anti-competitive behaviors that actually
harm then small business and Americans
and I don't know Rob if you have
thoughts on the rent-seeking or kind of
the harms to the economy as well you
know I find myself like almost every day
now struggling for new words right we
just like need a new vocabulary because
it's never it's never existed before to
describe this kind of stuff the you know
the Koch brothers have a decent
vocabulary on sort of crony capitalism
and if you sort of divorce it from
everything else they're talking about it
is it's pretty good but no one's ever
imagined anything like this
the mar-a-lago story where you know in
the one hand they've jumped the price
now for $200,000 because why not if
you're gonna whisper to the president
you should have to pay for the right
what you know the New York Times just
sort of got access to the partial list
of the members of the club and we're
able to sort then to talk to them and
the people are pretty willing apparently
to talk about what they do with the
president and in terms of this cronyism
what's so spectacular about that story
is the people there did not buy and yet
they didn't buy in for access to the
president no one possibly could have
foreseen that Donald Trump was going to
be President and they're just there but
you know they're pretty well-off people
includes another of the Koch brothers
among others and where they've described
is they do get to whisper in his ear and
he solicits it it is the it is exactly
cronyism it's like the buds that he
hangs out with what do you think oh why
by the way why don't you bid on the
twenty billion dollar wall because I
think you know the prices seem to be a
little high and the the you know the
informality of it and that's sort of the
total sense of corruption the I you know
again sorry norms the norms all old
standards are sort of now completely
gone and
does mean in ways that are going to be
big and small you know the Nordstrom
tweet to things that are gonna be much
bigger you're gonna have policy that's
made on behalf of who is the last guy
who talked to the president and again
the other sir besides just the
mar-a-lago and the club's if you look at
his daily schedule you know again I'll
feel everybody says I feel like it's
been 12 years but you know it's been a
month these in these constant meetings
with the CEOs who are describing the
policy then he get which he then sort of
parrots in some kind of weird way except
more extreme than anything they ever
would have asked for that's how
policymaking is being done right now you
know we're we're very worried about the
regulatory space you had Steve banning
yesterday say wants to destroy the
regulatory state he's got his own
pathway on that but for Trump it's these
guys from big industry and he likes that
people have the titles and and the shiny
metals to tell them what to do and this
hang out thing is is affecting the kind
of policy we're gonna see during the
administration I thought one of the
really really hitting home examples of
that was on their recent action to
revive the Dakota access pipeline and of
course you know horrible images of the
protesters water protectors camps being
burned to the ground just in the last
few days and Trump of course owned stock
in the company building the pipeline as
recently as 2015 energy transfer
partners so while a spokesman says these
since sold all of them I think without
having a full understanding of the
extent of Trump's financial holdings and
of course liabilities you know this is
really strikes me as the very swampy ran
against well it's traditional for
presidents although they're not required
to do it to file update at their form
278 and file it in May we did it in the
Obama administration we helped the
president prepare and he disclosed his
taxes around the same time we'll see
Trump doesn't have to do that we'll see
if he if he breaks that tradition as
well I just wanted to make two add-on
points to Rob's one is that he in a new
form of crony capitalism he's actually
brought his cronies into the
administration as
is purported informal advisors as
painter and I've said previously the
notion that Carl Icahn is anything other
than a special government employee is
hard to swallow he has a title he's been
involved in personnel decisions
reportedly helping pick the SEC head he
has a broad regulatory portfolio every
part of regulation those that directly
hits his pocketbook which he can then
use to support Trump and others in big
ways and they should a press release
that they're bringing him on that is not
an informal advisor that's a special
government employee who's subject to the
ethics laws but it's even worse than
that because he's made his own sons and
himself a crony he's it we need a new
term for it crony Oni ISM because bike
hanging on to his businesses all of
these decisions cycle back and putting
his sons in charge they cycle back to
his family members we don't even know
when he was because we don't have his
taxes we don't even know when he was
defending attacking Nordstrom's and if
defending his daughter we don't even
know if he was defending his own
investments in her businesses the family
often does those cross family
investments so the thing is so and it's
very important that we because of the
intensity of the wrongdoing that we
maintain the intensity of the outrage as
challenging as it is on a daily basis
and I think norm you've done great work
and Vikram in your experience but
looking at and fighting broader issues
of corruption in and of government and
norms specifically in the World Forum on
governance and Vikram in your experience
in Afghanistan can you talk a little bit
about how these financial conflicts
corrupt government broadly and then what
that means kind of in terms of a danger
really to liberal democracy and to the
idea of liberal democracy what's so
special about a non corrupt democracy
well a lot is special about a non
corrupt democracy primarily they're
there they are consistently both more
egalitarian and they and the peep
are far more prosperous than non corrupt
democracies corrupt democracies become
less equal and and are worse places to
live quite frankly so most people want
to live in a non corrupt democracy it
turns out Russia is a great model of a
corrupt democracy right now and so are
places like Afghanistan and a lot of
places that a lot of us have tried to
help over the years Republicans and
Democrats have spent a lot of time
trying to help countries break out of
cycles of corruption we are about to
enter a cycle of corruption and we're
gonna start seeing things that look very
familiar in this country to places we
talked about in Asia where I've worked
in transitional democracies where norm
has done a lot of work and it's it's a
it's a it's quite frankly frightening
and it and it should be a functioning
democracy depends more than almost
anything on transparency you have to
know what your leaders are up to and
that is why even countries in Africa
even countries in Asia one of the things
they'll do when they're really trying to
move past an era of crony governance and
cronyism and kleptocracy is they will
they will enact financial disclosure
laws it's one of the first things you do
we have a situation where by hook or by
crook the administration of the United
States of America is circumventing all
the norms and laws that we have had for
a long time on the books to make sure
that the United States has transparency
and financial disclosure some of them
are things that Trump likes to boast
about being able to do technically
legally and some of them are things like
norm has railed about on emoluments that
he really is in violation of the
Constitution and all of them right now
are kind of he's there skating through
on them but without question whether
legal or not they diminish the ability
of the people to know what's going on we
cannot know if he's motivated by profit
or the public interest in a given
exchange with Russia or with China or
any country that he might owe a lot of
money to or be dependent on for revenue
we cannot know whether he is subject to
leverage or pressure by a foreign power
who
something over him were one of his
family members through their business
ties we cannot know what how other
countries are gonna view America so
America's influence is going to be
diminished in a way he's making American
normal that's actually exactly I wanted
to ask you how do you know you travel
you know in your sphere
how do Trump's financial conflicts of
interests and appearance of corruption
impact the way people are now perceiving
American democracy and therefore how
does that affect America's standing and
power in the world
well IIIi think it is safe to say that
if this persists if the Trump
administration basically rewrites the
rules that we've really had I would say
since the 70s in place to maximize the
transparency and to have ethics laws and
to have all sorts of accountability over
our leadership I think it will change
basically everything about global
governance so this is that sounds
extreme but the United States has been a
one of the leading lights in terms of
this is the way you have a functioning
democracy that can sustain itself where
the leaders are accountable to the
people writ large not just to the voters
and that the people have leaders who are
serving them right would they work for
us right and so the that between the
it's the United States and Europe that
have been able to lead the charge here
as this changes if the United States
fades from the sea if that means that
the world's largest economy is no longer
playing by those exemplary rules I think
the effect can't be overstated on what
that's going to do to the trajectory for
norms around the world you know the the
the United States things like the Open
Government Partnership that the Obama
administration created which got dozens
and dozens of nations to sign on to
specific steps they would take to have
transparency and governance those kinds
of things fall apart if the United
States itself is not following those
sorts of norms so I think it it portends
dark days for everybody that wants to
live in a democratic society well I have
several other questions on Russia
and and the exact quote was from 2008
Donald Trump jr. Russians make up a
pretty dispro disproportionate
cross-section of a lot of our assets we
see a lot of money pouring in from
Russia so obviously well actually let's
let's do that before I was going to say
I'd also before this gets too bleak turn
to some of the remedies of which there
are many and I definitely want to talk
about the courts and the legal action
but just specifically for a moment and
with the just the the newest daily
outrage of the the White House you know
back-channeling to the FBI about the
investigation of the White House can you
say a little bit about the significance
of trumps unknown financial
relationships or debts to Russian
oligarchs and really what we need on
that front so look there's nothing wrong
with the Trump Organization having done
business with all sorts of entities all
around the world the question is which
is true I have nothing to do with Russia
I have no connections I have no
businesses in Russia or a whole lot of
money is flowing in from Russia one of
those two things is true the way to know
it is transparency release the
information let us judge for ourselves
the people to whom you as as congressman
sarbanes said or say you're returning
the power to let us judge that it is
impossible to know and it may not matter
for a while
but we will never know in any dealing
with Putin we don't know is he nice to
Putin just because of these business
dealings or is he nice to Putin because
he genuinely thinks we should have a
different relationship with Russia which
may be a valid which may be a valid
thing to want to do we can't know we
can't trust his motives and others are
gonna play him other countries are gonna
play him based on this well maybe this
is for the remedies section but and we
have to plug caps very good paper which
talks about the remedies and there are
remedies and I just want to sound a
slightly less bleak note because in the
silver linings Department I would have
preferred not to be harvesting all these
silver linings there has been an
extraordinary activation of the checks
and balances that you talk about in the
case
paperless and and I I think we've seen
an energy in our American democracy in
the courts in Congress where chairman
Goodlatte will be considering the nabla
resolution to flush out just this
information and we've seen these and I
hope it'll happen again when that's
considered on Tuesday we've seen
constituents appearing physically in
there the American people appearing in
districts ad offices coming to the hill
I hope that that hearing room will be
crowded with people of both parties who
are concerned about this and people are
tweeting and they're on social media and
and even the executive branch Trump's
own executive branch is getting into the
action with the OGE doing now a review
calling the White House on the carpet as
they can doing a review of the Kellyanne
Conway or OGE wall job speaking out
about the president's own conflicts that
was extraordinary so we're seeing a lot
of activity and that gives me hope and I
think the rest of the world is watching
that and you know it's there's an
advantage to the rest of the world when
I was ambassador I would often say I
would talk about things that were amiss
and there are people people in the room
who came to these annual gatherings we
would have or otherwise as I look around
several friends who were there in Prague
helping with this I'd say to the Czechs
you know and to the central Europeans
the Europeans we would all gather
periodically I'd say look we're in this
together the United States is not
perfect neither are you you can learn
from us we can learn from you I think
there's a lot of value in the rest of
the world seeing the popular and the
institutional and the states and the
state AG is stepping forward the checks
and balances coming into play and I
actually believe nobody knows what's at
the end of the path but I believe if we
exercise the remedies in your paper and
and Congress congressman sarbanes a
leader with his colleagues the navalore
resolution on Tuesday if people rise up
around these kinds of things that our
democracy can actually may actually
emerge strong
and our world leadership stronger but
it's gonna be a lot of work to get there
the glass half full in a lot of fight
and of course Public Citizen has been
doing a lot to motivate folks to be
participating we have I don't want to
let norm get away with this uplifting
story so I wanted to add a bleak note
before we go to the remedies because I
think you were getting at things that
are really actually there was there was
a piece that you were getting at that
that I think we should we should
highlight which is that there are and
again sort of there's an international
story there's more to be told obviously
but on the domestic side it it does flow
through it starts with him but it flows
through the administration and it's
going to its we're gonna have unending
scandal over the next four years I think
that's a virtual certainty and it's not
just about trumpet it's not just gonna
be about the tweets because it follows
from the leadership of the president and
the way that White House is conducting
its business this FBI thing actually is
just astounding but leaving just a nick
in the conflict of interest area where
the creation of all these advisory
committees the reliance on people and
self interested parties to set
government policy we're seeing at the
Department of Education on privatization
of Education we're seeing it lining up
for the passage out of contracts on the
infrastructure bill we're seeing it on
this regulatory thing with Carl Icahn
which is the most astounding of all
abuses that that's completely pervasive
you see it in the cabinet and it's gonna
flow down people you know if you look at
the cabinet and the the criminal or the
criminal record and the wrongdoing
record of the cabinet appointees in any
past administration any one of these
people would have been thought so far
beyond the pale it would have been
inconceivable they'd be confirmed but he
flooded his own with people who either
themselves violated the law frequently
or their companies violated the law
frequently and they're now
nonetheless were able to be forced
through and they also are going to
follow with just massive pay back to
their industries and all kinds of more
technically corrupt dealings and we're I
think that's what we're going to see
over the next four years so it does
start with with the president but it's
going to be pervasive through government
and really dangerous ways I think that's
true and I actually do want to highlight
a
place where I think we will be able to
see clearly whether the rule of law is
being file followed or whether you know
legal chicanery and kind of the pushing
the bounds of the law in the as a
private citizen you know might do that
is completely inappropriate in the
sphere of public service when we look at
the GSA review of trumps lease on the
you know on the general post office
building now the Trump International
Hotel and site of so many of these
constitutional violations so and I think
you know we talked about it in the paper
chiefess has actually asked for some
information about this so perhaps we
will get a source of oversight from that
side of the bench as well car you know
Rupp Cummings has review is reviewing
issues there and the GSA says they are
reviewing it Norman did you oh I know I
just I wanted to say Robin I actually
live in the same apartment building so
he lives in the glass half empty side of
the building I live in the glass
you weren't meaning to say that all
members of the cabinet you're just
saying some members of the cabinet ours
because there's there's any many many I
would say many but I think there's we
should say in fairness there's some very
respected decent outstanding people in
the administration and it's not and that
also is the glass half full but the
other thing I wanted to say just maybe a
tenth or maybe I think that's too severe
and I wanted to say that the first
complaint that crew filed I think it was
the first complaint intentionally the
first complaint filed against Trump in
the country because I had somebody
standing at the GSA watching the
swearing in as soon as his hand came off
the Bible we filed a complaint with the
GSA about that lease so I agree with you
great that is a very important
opportunity and it's a question of the
rule of law the least set so why don't
you tell us about that lease for a
minute but then tell us about the
constitutional emolument suit
and you know the accountability that we
will see in that on the lease again this
is in the in the positive side I
couldn't get out of bed in the morning
if I didn't think that there were green
shoots and signs of hope and people in
the cabinet who will stand up to Trump
when he has his worst impulses huge
demand from America I will say that that
optimism and so you can look at GSA
which has been totally craven including
by the way before because there's stuff
that they could have been should have
done when Obama was still in the White
House certainly in the post period or
you can you can focus on GSA or you can
focus on OGE
on Walt Chow who's been unbelievably
brave people didn't understand it they
didn't understand his tweets which
actually I thought were very funny he
was in a gentle way trolling of the
president-elect now we know through FOIA
that the reason he did that was because
they were ignoring him and stiff-arming
him on his efforts to engage as I
engaged on behalf of President Obama
with og with a Republican a Mitch
McConnell a pointee recommended by Mitch
to by Senator McConnell to Bush director
Cusick wonderful man we got along great
we never had a problem even though we
was a you know Republican so he's been
very heroic so I can compare the failure
of GSA with the heroism of oh gee GSA if
you're watching it's not too late to
show shelbs courage we need you to act
and if not crew will be following up on
our complaint and then I think we do
want to take audience question I just I
do look I do have a lot of confidence in
the institutions that we've built over a
few centuries of democracy and I think
we'll get through this I'm not trying to
be completely half-empty or half-full
but in the foreign policy sphere
you know domestically we just we just
heard about how some of the what he can
do through regulation and
elation and the dismantling of the
regulatory system in the foreign policy
sphere the president's the president's
power is is really vast and so this is
this becomes a matter that Americans
should worry about in terms of not just
corruption and influence and what about
Putin but it matters of war in peace
what kind of judgments will he be making
if he has to come to us and ask us to
support him in sending American young
men and women into harm's way we should
know that it's about the national
interest and we should have no doubt
that that is the only thing at play and
so long as these conflicts persist this
is not a difficult remedy just follow
normal patterns of behavior that have
been set for decades and it sets all of
this aside and none of us would be
having we wouldn't need your wonderful
paper but I think it is that fundamental
and and in the foreign policy realm we
need to know and I we actually start the
paper with a section on the threats to
national security and a quote saying
protections against corruption and
protect and ethics rules really are kind
of national security protections for
government and we've never had a
president with named businesses
throughout the world in in stable
regions so we're gonna go back to bleak
for a moment I mean that's the when we
see the Washington Post had an analysis
where he's spending more time tweeting
than at intelligence briefings I think
there have been historical instances
when a president ignores an urgent
security briefing and what can happen
mere months after so that is I think
something that I I don't think there's
any precedence retweeting more than
going to name three things that's true
thank you thank you for parsing as
always Rob but yes that's I I think that
there are very serious national security
implications for the safety and security
of Americans at home with regard to the
disparagement that from President Trump
to groups around the world and then his
distraction from
important roles you know he is not just
a for-profit president he appears to be
a part-time president so there will be
avenues of accountability and tools for
oversight through the courts the genius
of our system is our separation of
powers so we know that the courts and
Congress are in fact co-equal branches
we firmly believe that the rule of law
will be upheld visa vie constitutional
violations both currently in court on
the foreign emoluments but also there
are domestic emoluments concerns that
you know just come right dovetailing
with that but you know the Congress has
a lot of bills and opportunities for
resolutions and then I do think that
it's really just a question of a
drumbeat of public pressure and the Free
Press really continuing to do the job of
uncovering this with Americans you know
pushing them every step so just time for
a few questions let's I saw your hand in
the red shirt in the back yep in the
light pink shirt all right my name is
Dave price a freelance journalist and I
want to keep it simple because Donald
Trump makes my head hurt but the idea of
exists only your head well other parts
too but hold you we'll just go here for
now okay so we have a constitution
correct in the United States and
Constitution is written and in there
there's a clause that supposedly deals
with you mullets and it either says you
can have gifts or you can everybody
agree with that so far I'm not off-base
and there seems to be some limited or
vast indication that the president
United States is in violation of the
Constitution so my question is and I
know some of you started it so it's not
completely a fair question but okay what
happens number one what is the process
of going after him on that and secondly
so he's guilty so he gives the gifts
back I mean what what what's the
ultimate of that where does that lead
Joe thank you very much
well we crew are part of a bipartisan
group filed suit we did our GSA suit on
the Friday of the swearing-in and then
we dropped our emolument suit on Monday
after three days of collecting Trump
collecting illegal foreign cash and
benefits whether gifts are earned of any
kind whatever and we do believe that
it's a strong case on the merits it's
pretty amazing that you'd have these
kinds of blatant constitutional
violations and it actually set a tone
for all of these other transgressions
that we've seen since the
unconstitutional AO which has the
monuments issues also because why is
Trump banning Muslims from the seven
countries that are too poor to do
business with them when you have
neighboring countries Egypt UAE Saudi
that he has that business connection was
that have actually exported
terror attacks to United States soil it
makes no sense at all so it set the tone
that unconstitutionally set the tone for
the unconstitutional Muslim ban it set
the tone for others violations the
Kellyanne Conway breaking the rules and
the chief of staff now intruding on an
FBI investigation they're running
willy-nilly on the road breaking the
remedy is we think that the court will
order him to stop now we're not asking
for the money to be paid back for a
variety of technical legal reasons the
court should say no more a monuments mr.
president and then he's got to deal with
how he limits there's an easy answer
this is where we're gonna end up he's
gonna have to appoint a trustee again
bipartisan experts including tea party
leaders and extreme Clinton critics and
others have said you got to do this he's
gonna come back to it he's gonna have to
appoint a trustee he's not just going to
turn over management as he's done but
ownership to the trustee to liquidates
got to sell and reinvest in investments
that
our conflict-free that's what
everybody's done for 40 years with far
fewer conflicts and risk than Donald
Trump and I do think that you know it's
important to remember David Cole the the
head of the American Civil Liberties
Union has written if courts could order
President Bush in an ongoing armed
conflict to subject his detentions of
enemy combatants to legal review surely
they can order President Trump to
conform his business interests to the
express demands of the Constitution so I
think that's again a question of just
the rule of law both the black letter
who knew we were all you know
originalist the black letter textual
prohibitions and just upholding the rule
of law it works from both an originalist
analysis and a analysis of the structure
purpose and intent
whichever lens you view it through it's
forbidden
afternoon Thank You Liz my name is
Matthew Murray and until about a month
ago I was part of a senior team at the
Obama administration that was working on
anti-corruption both in our commercial
diplomacy our national security policy
and in our trade policy and I want to
just turn the panel's attention to what
you might call the policy remedies to
the current predicament and I but first
I want to I do want to applaud the work
you've done already to shine a spotlight
on what's happening and to hold
accountability standards very high and
and now I just want to have you turn to
what are the deeper structural dilemmas
that we face with this the first
question would be how do we tie what
you're doing individually and as
organizations to the broader question of
how Americans get more access to
Economic Opportunity
how do we tie this to the jobs and
growth agenda domestically and what are
we going to do both to take the case to
the grassroots but also more importantly
tie what can appear to some to be a
technical set of issues to the broader
economic question of can we trust
globalization does free trade actually
work is free trade the problem or is it
the solution and all those very
important questions and and by the way
one of the one of the big initiatives I
championed when I was in the
administration is to get these free
trade agreements to include
state-of-the-art anti-corruption
chapters to even out enforcement across
the globe so that it doesn't in fact
increase access to economic opportunity
that's a first sort of policy remedy
question a second one is the Obama
administration literally did dozens of
great things with ambassador Eisen as a
champion in Central Europe to promote
anti-corruption rule of law and good
governance throughout the world and we
did that in part because we were wanted
to use this as a way to fight terrorism
and and we did this in part because we
understood that corruption is a
recruiting tool
and we we did this in part because we
understand that President Putin for
example uses corruption as a as a
foreign policy platform and so a
question is what are we doing to take
inventory of what President Obama did
and makes goes forward in other words
there's no reason to cede the ground
there's no reason to say the open
government partnership at least in my
view was is now defunct or something
like that so what are we doing to make
sure that this current administration is
held accountable to the progress being
made sorry for the long winded questions
but for your work Rob do you want to
talk about the the economy like how to
tie this to these questions of jobs and
bringing it home to people yeah well
first on the on the second part of it
you know as you do know you know one of
the first legislative acts of the
Congress along with approving the
cabinet was repealing a really important
anti-corruption measure that was
included in dodd-frank that requires oil
gas and mining companies to disclose
their payments to foreign governments
which the president happily sign in
which Rex Tillerson had lobbied for when
he'd been had the repeal of which he'd
lobbied for when you've been head of
ExxonMobil totally unconnected I'm sure
so it's gonna be hard to see an
aggressive anti-corruption I think
agenda going forward from this
administration globally on the on the
domestic side I mean I think it's maybe
a little bit less about sort of policy
solutions and more about sort of the
political and the framing issues around
it but I think what we're gonna try to
do is we Public Citizen I think all of
us collectively is talking about how the
conflict issues relate to policy so I
gave a couple examples Tax Policy is
obviously going to be a massive fight we
got some clarification from Steve
minuchin about what Steven minuchin
about what he wants tax policy to look
like and it's cuts for large
corporations and I think connecting that
and Trump's personal interest in this to
what happens going to mean for accurate
people is going to be an important part
of the story
they've already signaled they want to
roll back as much of dodd-frank as they
possibly can
that is obviously connected both to the
Carl Icahn story and to all of his
intermingling with Wall Street interests
not all of what you've disclosed but we
know he's got 150 lenders to whom he's
got some ongoing obligations
there's no way to talk about repealing
the dodd-frank rules without saying
you're completely trashing your populist
message and you sort of go down the list
with with these things and I think
that's going to be the way to connect
the personal conflict issues to the to
the big picture policy questions and
there's you know there's just no way for
them to square the circle there's no way
to talk about these things as populist
measures there's things that are
popularly and publicly supported you
know which i think is worrisome in its
way because the conflict between the
populist base and the populist campaign
and the reality of how they're going to
govern that's going to become a very
apparent conflict and it's going to
require I think very aggressive things
on sort of the worst nationalists most
xenophobic anti terror trumped-up anti
terror stuff to just a hold the anti
populist or the populist frame when
they're adopting an anti populist
economic policy I think that's that's
actually a scary thing we're gonna have
to watch out for going forward when I
speak to you Obama corruption measures
and such a wonderful part and I worked
with Matthew very closely he attended
our annual meetings in in Prague where
we brought together people from Europe
and really around the world to talk
about just these questions in the
international context who knew they'd
have such relevance and I it's a little
name-drop be but you'll forgive me for
saying so in addition that the Open
Government Partnership was actually born
in my office physically at the White
House when I was the ethics are not by
me but by a wonderful colleague on the
National Security Council jeremy
Weinstein I still work with coming in
and saying you guys are doing so many
great things domestically what if we
came up with a way to drive it
internationally Jeremy and you know we
started going back and forth and back
and forth and out of that his idea and
that conversation came the OGP which i
still work on i
in a paper at the OGP in my Brookings
capacity on whether open government
works or not and I will now pivot to the
answer I think we need to have one of
the failures of those of us who believe
in these things is we have not unwrapped
signals this in his answer to we need to
be able to make an affirmative case not
just talking to ourselves I'm a
progressive I'm on the Left not just
talking to ourselves on the left but we
need to be able to make a strong
affirmative case that is heard in the
center and even on the right I've been
doing a lot of speaking to Tea Party
groups lately about common cause issues
and some of them are very concerned
about some of the Trump stuff very
concerned so we need to have a vision of
opportunity that is broadly persuasive
in that has heroes and villains that has
a narrative that is broadly persuasive
that can again command an electoral
majority in the United States and that
fits into a global picture I think the
American people are more generous than
America first but we need to make that
case and the anti-corruption part of it
needs to be woven in it cannot be a
free-standing transparency integrity
decency needs to be woven into that
story and that's going to take us some
time I think again inveterate optimists
that I am I think part of what we're
seeing now is in our American Way not
from the top down not from Washington
even from wonderful institutions like
kapor Public Citizen or crew or
Brookings but from the bottom up we're
seeing these grassroots efforts to
articulate that vision and we all need
to work together to make that case and
that's how we'll keep that the dream of
integrity in domestic and international
government alive as part of that
coherent narrative I think oh well I
think that's true but I also I wouldn't
cook no I'm
I'm like moderators point of privilege
for a moment I think that all of those
things about open government and
transparency and you know accountability
in that way are entirely necessary
we should also just situate that in the
larger problem in American you know
governance and and I think we're seeing
this you know around the world as well
but that there has been such a growth of
economic inequality there has been such
a growth of political inequality people
elected this man on for any number of
reasons I suppose but one particularly
was his pledge to drain the swamp so we
did a lot of trust in government
research and saw that you know over 83
percent 84 percent believe that American
government is working for the benefit of
wealthy special interests and you know
lobbyists etc and I think that we need
to do in addition to maintaining
bare-bones
transparent anti-corruption measures we
really need to adopt affirmative
democracy solutions to return to rebuild
this bridge of responsiveness from
elected representatives to the folks
they're meant to represent it's not just
Trump with this dangerous unprecedented
and unconstitutional conflicts of
interest it's it's really the water
everyone is now swimming in it's kind of
the whole system is set up too and kind
of based on this conflicts of interest
because if you're dependent on only
folks with a bunch of money to raise
money to run for office you then end up
being a lot more responsive to it's not
a quite those wealthy specialists and
that really breaks the link and it means
that folks that are lower income folks
that have been politically marginalized
ninety-three million eligible Americans
did not vote at all in 2016 and I think
you know one reason is because they
think their voice is no longer count
Washington is broken etc etc we have to
hold the line on these absurd conflicts
that are really a threat to our entire
system but really answer the call for
rebuilding American democracy in a
responsive accountable way that ensures
fair representation so that's I think
that we might okay wait there
one more question so why don't we go to
you thank you I worked for the
government for over thirty years before
I retired and I'm a little concerned
about public citizens the idea that the
people at the top have so much power
that they can corrupt government in
inside government because when you work
for government you're restricted on
political speech
you have to sign non-disclosure you have
to sign so many documents that give away
your rights you have to pee in the cup
you know once a year you have to give
your taxes up to dip and not on your
taxes but document all of your wealth
down to the name and number of every
bond you have just to work in government
so my question really is we have a
president who says none of that applies
to me and you have a workforce who was
just burdened with compliance of all
kinds of compliance and restrictions on
political speech and in interaction and
I never hear anybody from the
progressive side say we need to change
the way we box in government employees
and and restrict them so that we can
have more political exchange and say the
trumpet there's a tension and I think
when Trump is saying no no way that that
applied to me I don't have to know
complex invention don't apply to me how
am I going to then a nepotism applies to
me as an employee you know even though
I've left the government I still have
requirements to forever keep secrets I
think I know where you worked I think
anyone who's worked in government is
going to have to deal with this paradox
that everybody that works for president
Trump right now compassed to comply with
a serious set of ethics requirements and
that he's saying that he does not you
can't hire your daughter or son or
son-in-law in your government job but he
can you know it goes back to again about
40 years we built up a framework of
ethics and it's probably overly
burdensome in some ways it probably
could be improved and reformed but to
have the top throwing that all out for
himself
it sends it sends a signal down through
the whole system it's going to create a
lot of resentment and the fact is what
do you need you need trust right
you need trust between you and the
citizens you need trust between your
workforce all the departments and
agencies dedicated career public
servants anyone who's worked in
government knows that the the this sort
of popular reputation of federal workers
as lazy etcetera etcetera is nonsense
it's very hardworking people that work
grueling hours that would mostly make a
lot more money doing something else that
that they're not going to trust somebody
who says there's one standard for you
and there's a different standard for me
that's really disturbing for where our
system is going to be governed over the
next few years it suggests we'll have a
very bumpy ride that is indeed the
question is how our system will be
governed and how these avenues of
accountability and tools for oversight
may help protect some of these ethical
standards so I want to give really big
round of thanks and applause for our
panelists you really thank you so much
for your time and contributions here
today we're adjourned thank you so much